I like to have it off right as sort of
thanks yeah why not yeah that's cheer
the idea of
sex Russell Brand is recently all over
the newspapers and I'm getting messages
constantly people saying oh my gosh have
you seen this about Russell bran can you
believe that he's a rapist can you
believe he's a sex offender here's the
thing right now Russell Brand is
innocent and I personally think that it
is an orchestrated attack ATT on his
character to try to smear his name
because probably he's saying stuff on
his own platform which is affecting and
hurting extremely powerful people this
is so obvious this happens time and time
again how many people do you see that
speak up against the establishment the
first thing they do is they will brand
you as a conspiracist or they'll say oh
this person's crazy Kaner West is crazy
Russell Brands they branded him a
conspiracist but then if you continue
going then it'll be okay okay let's find
some dirt let's try and if we can't find
any dirt let's just make some stuff up
allegedly Russell bran did this this
this this this if you put the word
allegedly before something in my mind
I'll just ignore the rest of the
sentence allegedly what according to who
literally a man on the street could say
Samuel Lees is a murderer and then
allegedly I'm a murderer because one
person said it anonymously so Russell
Brandon's got a whole bunch of people
anonymously saying that he raped them
that he he's uh sexually assaulted them
all kinds of stuff and as a result of
that now his name is absolute mud and
he's really going through it and I
personally think that it's wrong so I'm
going to watch the short video that
channel 4 have just put up I'm going to
react to it give my opinion on it and
then I'm going to be speaking about why
I believe strongly that Russell Brand is
actually innocent so let's watch
this I like to have it off right as sort
of straight away within the first few
seconds this guy is a standup comedy
right a standup comedian he's been he's
he's probably done thousands of hours
worth of content they've searched
through all of his content and tried to
find stuff where he was talking about
sex which might be you know a little bit
creepy might have said some things that
out of context don't look great and put
eerie music over the top this is clearly
a character assassination on the guy I
can tell straight away from 5 seconds
in yeah why not yeah let's cheer the
idea of
sex
sex the love of it the dogged unashamed
pursuit of it Russell Bran's thing this
is stuff that he said years ago and at
the time was protected when he was
working for Channel 4 and the BBC and he
was on the TV no problem now he's got
his own media channel platform and he's
talking about the world economic forum
and he's talking about the banks he's
talking about the H hypocrisy of the
system Suddenly It's like oh my gosh can
you believe he said this where were you
at the time
now tonight off stage it sees him
accused of rape sexual assault
controlling and abusive Behavior because
skipped over the word accused there you
know now it's seen him accused of rape
and control
and uncovered in a major investigation
by Channel 4 dispatches the times and
the Sunday
Times thing people think that oh
recently people said about me oh you're
in the sun oh the sun of scum we hate
the Sun people don't realize that all
the media Outlets are controlled by the
same people anyway so they're all
everything's
orchestrated my underwear pulling it to
the side I'm telling him to get off me
and he won't get off like holding me up
against the wall pushing himself in
[Music]
me it's based on the testimony of five
women who agreed to share their stories
actors have been used in some cases and
in others voices have been here's what I
want to know the five people right now
out of the you know Russell Brand has
got millions of followers and out of
those followers is going to be some some
of them that just don't like him anyway
those five people that are now saying
that he sexually assaulted them or raped
them I want to know number one why are
they speaking out now at the same time
why are they speaking out anonymously
why are the people actors and most
importantly why did they not go to the
police at the time and maybe they'll say
oh I was too scared to go to the police
at the time didn't want to all right
fine but why now a decade later when you
want to speak out and you feel
comfortable speaking out why now are you
not going to the police why are you
going to the media and most importantly
this is what I want to know is were they
paid £20,000 to come and speak out and
if so who paid them these are the
questions that I think we need to be
demanding answers for right
now Alice was just 16 in 2006 when she
first met Russell Brand he Russell Brand
is saying that he's completely innocent
and it's absolutely untrue Anonymous
people who are being uh voice actors and
are saying that he's guilty so okay
let's just let it go to court report it
to the police let it go to court this is
absolutely wrong the law of the land is
that you are innocent until proven
guilty which means that if Russell Brand
is a rapist then before we can judge and
say he's a rapist he needs to be seen by
a judge and there needs to be proof and
evidence that he is in fact a rapist
until that happens the media saying he's
allegedly a rapist and talking about him
and putting eerie music and completely
assassinating his character is
completely unethical and wrong we've
seen this happen time and time again I
mean look at Cliff Richard who was
accused of being a rapist took years
before his name was cleared and by the
time your name is cleared ah it's
irrelevant anyway I personally think
that Russell Brand is probably saying
things that are upsetting people who are
in positions of power who have just
decided right let's just ruin him let's
ruin his uh his
reputation the allegations are from the
early 0s until
2013 was the I wonder what Russell Brand
has said that's upset some people let's
see Russell Bran's YouTube channel and
have a look at his most popular videos
let's see what's what is upsetting
people so
much okay hey vaccine passports this is
where it leads we've been lied to about
why the Ukrainian War Began another one
of his videos war is profitable this is
how okay maybe that's the reason that
they're going after him maybe just maybe
another video about Co they're lying to
you if science caused Co what's next
Trump was right about Clinton and Russia
Collision they're not going to like
that oh here's the big one 2.7 million
views you will own nothing and you will
be happy the great reset World economic
Forum
video The Great reset Bill Gates and
farming what's going
on Trump right okay the world's gone
nuts Russell Brand the truth I mean the
media like no you can't talk about Trump
we want to talk about Trump and we will
say what we've been told and paid to say
his videos getting millions of views I
can see why eventually there might be
some people that might want to um shut
him down what the great reset is not a
conspiracy says Russell
Brand another video one year ago so this
is what they've been hiding it I don't
know about you but it kind of makes me
think when I see someone like this
getting clearly an orchestrated attack
all at once suddenly five people five
women saying he did this this this over
a decade later the media ready with the
stories pens at at the ready bang eerie
music over over the actor's voices all
Anonymous it makes me think man I want
to go watch his videos some more and see
what he's been saying because clearly
there's some truth in it first they
tried to shut him down I'm sure they've
deleted a load of his YouTube videos and
I'm sure he's had a lot of strikes
theyve branded him a conspirac a
conspiracy theorist which is a term that
was actually created by the government
do you know that what is what is a
conspiracy theorist when when everyone
anyone was talking against the
government the government would say bang
they're a conspir a conspiracy theorist
what does it actually do you
mean who really runs the world Russell
Brand big farmer is selling what now
it's official they lied meta is
brainwashing your children at school
misinformation is now terrorism was
Trump right about Co pill all
along is there a god yes this is why I
think they're upset with him so if he's
guilty or if he's innocent we I I think
we have to assume he's innocent unless
he's being proven guilty the media
should stop talking about him and if
you're watching this and you're thinking
well what should I do about this what I
would say is um just bear in mind that
the media are all owned by the same
people don't believe what you read in
the headlines because most of it is
garbage and it makes me personally a
little bit concerned I mean the media
have come for me and attacked me in the
past but it's just like man we see this
time and time again and I hope that this
is the Tipping Point where we realize
the pattern when everyone speaks out
when everyone has their own channel own
platform and speaks what they believe to
be truth and speaks against the
establishment we see the pattern again
and again it's almost getting boring now
it's predictable it's obviously a
personality and and character
assassination on him I hope he's
innocent but I believe that he is
innocent until he's been proven guilty
I'm going to go watch some more Russell
Brown's videos right now I'm going to
leave some comments and show him some
support I hope you do the same thing too
and I'd love to know your comments and
thoughts let me know in the comments
I'll see you next time